ohio just voted to approve a bill to arm
teachers
this is going to be a controversial bill
because the democrats hate
guns
and the democrats want to get rid of
guns and a bill to arm teachers is going
to encourage people to have more guns if
any either it'll
keep the gun the gun number about the
same or it will increase the number of
guns out there and so the democrats are
very upset about this
but this is a very good law
the ohio republican governor mike dewine
is expected to sign this bill
that the gop legislature
the gop led legislature passed this is a
good bill
just uh
here's how you know it's a good bill
for a moment
take away every preconceived
desire that you've got in politics all
the rules you want everything you want
to change just take that away and just
focus for one second
on a school
you've got a school
two schools you got one school
where the teachers and the staff are
permitted to carry guns
and you don't know which teachers are
exercising that right and which teachers
are not but you know that there are
going to be guns in this school
then you've got a school that's a gun
free zone where you know no guns are
allowed anywhere around that school
maybe a resource officer is allowed to
carry one maybe
which school do you think is more likely
to be shot up by a lunatic
which one
the one where you don't know
if you bust into that school with a gun
if you're going to be taken out by that
guy or that guy or that guy or all of
them at once
or the school where everyone's a sitting
duck obviously it's the former
regardless of what you think about guns
second step are school shootings being
carried out by teachers with their guns
or school shootings being carried out by
aids with their guns
no the school shootings are always
carried out by crazy weirdo
students many of whom show a lot of
warning signs that are completely
ignored
because often of political correctness
and because of neglect and because of
inefficiency and sometimes corruption of
the schools
but what we know for sure that's a
separate issue what we know for sure is
the school shootings are not being
carried out by teachers with their guns
or aids with their guns
so it's not going to increase the risk
to students
and it is going to decrease the risk if
you want to reduce the likelihood of
school shootings
there is no question
are arming or allowing teachers to arm
themselves and aids to arm themselves
would accomplish that there's no i don't
i don't see how you could argue
otherwise the only thing you could argue
is well we don't want more guns out
there well guns are just bad generally
and so we want fewer guns not more guns
so no more guns
but that's a totally sep now you're just
talking about guns
in a way that is almost entirely
unrelated to school shootings
so on this issue the libs have to pick
they've got a very stark choice before
them
protect kids
or pursue their mostly unrelated gun
control agenda
they're mutually exclusive
and the libs are totally picking the
ladder uniformly almost i think without
exception
and the republicans are choosing the
former
you might you might say well it's just
because republicans love guns yeah
republicans do love guns and they do a
lot of republicans do at least yeah
that's true it's just because
republicans love their second amendment
right yup you're damn right we do uh-huh
but that again that's sort of beside the
point here i'm not talking in the
abstract i'm not talking about some
grand ideology i'm just talking about
the practical question what is more
likely to protect kids at schools
the shooter goes in and he doesn't know
which teachers and aides have guns or
shooter goes in sitting ducks he knows
it's a gun-free zone it's obviously the
former we i i know we don't we don't get
the libs to admit basic facts these days
men are not women babies or babies but
but come on if we're being serious we're
being sincere we're having a good faith
debate obviously
that policy would reduce the likelihood
of a mass shooting in a school and the
libs don't care because they're pursuing
their own agenda furthermore libs in
california are now making it harder to
identify threats
people who could cause violence at
schools earlier on there's the
california senate which just passed a
bill no longer requiring teachers to
report incidents to the police
this is senate bill 1273
states that current law holds that a
person quote who willfully disturbs any
public school or any public school
meeting is guilty of a misdemeanor and
shall be punished by a fine if not more
than five hundred dollars uh this bill
would make it so that enrolled students
would no longer be held liable for such
an offense
so the students would the school would
not report these incidents to
authorities
now you might say look if a student
is messing around at school and i don't
know he does something stupid he pulls a
prank he disrupts the class
the class clown does the class clown
need to be reported to the police every
time he pulls a prank no
i don't think so
but what if students are
causing
real disruptions what if students are
exhibiting really troubling behavior
do you think that the schools should
report that to authorities well
if your
goal is to reduce the likelihood of
violence at schools
there's no question here
of course the schools should report the
behavior
but if you are pursuing a different
agenda if you are pursuing the agenda of
abolish the police the the agenda of
we've got an over over incarceration
problem the agenda of we shouldn't
punish people for doing bad things
especially if they're of a protected
race or a protected class or protected
geographic area that would be
inequitable and terrible and racist and
bigoted and whatever pc nonsense they
want to spend if you're pursuing that
agenda then you say yeah don't just
brush it under the rug
when a a transgender bathroom comes at
the heart of of a horrible rape that
occurs in a school loudoun county
virginia when a guy wearing a dress goes
in and rapes a girl in the girl's
bathroom
and the guy's allowed into the girls
bathroom because of these insane
transgender policies well uh if you want
to protect kids obviously you don't let
boys in the girls room if you want to
pursue your radical abstract sexual
agenda then you have to let boys into
the girls room and so what do you do if
it's a former case you fix the problem
if it's the latter case you transfer the
boy to another school and you sweep it
under the rug what did the libs do in
loudoun county what are the libs doing
in california what are the libs doing
all over it has nothing to do with
protecting kids it has everything to do
with
with pursuing their own unrelated agenda
when the two come into conflict they
always pick
the ladder i'm glad you like that clip
now
you know what you have to do you gotta
ring
smash
click
like
tap
dab twerk i don't know you gotta
subscribe to the michael knowles show
right here on youtube and also on apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
make sure to do that right this very
second we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you